vous avez créé un million de pauvres en
plus déjà des chômeurs en plus et plans
sociaux en pagaille 20% de la population
française qui pensent au suicide
les étudiants qui n'en peuvent plus et
créhin d d d d asphalte hurel vous avez
créé la 10e' économistes la france est
devenue ce qu'on appelle une démocratie
défaillante bah oui c'est une horreur on
nous serre la vis comme on dit on se
relâche la langue arabe ou non mais
écoutez moi de débuter mois jusqu'au
proposition est ce que tu vois moi j'en
ai dit madame le meilleur
épidémiologiste au monde qui s'appelle
monsieur ioannidis g l'étude ici si vous
la donne les solutions de l'université
répondre elle a démontré et alors vous
pourrez dire c'est un abruti vous voulez
moi je lui fais plus confiance à
monsieur vers un test
il a démontré que vos mesures de
restriction il a étudié ça ne servait à
rien ça ne change pas la dynamique du
virus est la preuve je vous donne l'un
d'eux je donne la suède il donne
l'espagne trouve ses restos là et
s'abaisse bing en france
vous êtes en train de détruire le pays
notre démocratie
nos libertés le psychisme il ya des
drames psychiatrique le moral minutes on
est encore jeunes français alors moi je
disais ça la solution c'est que vous
nous remettez dans un monde normal
non mais nous arrêter à nous
infantiliser mais on fait de la
prévention d'une demi heure
toutes les et s'il vous plaît son
activité fatigué je suis mort excusez
moi mais je suis désolé c'est le chef du
gouvernement il ya l'europe par bonheur
le droit d'avoir une opposition cour
d'appel et là c'est un monologue de vos
nom et adresse qu il nous coupe sans
arrêt alors aidé tout 500 sinistrés se
faire en mairie avec ses règles ici ils
auront la parole et lui sont les régions
va prendre la suite chéri s'il vous
plaît ne vous osez dire que la suède a
plus de mortalité que la france et que
vous ne connaissez pas le doxil épaules
lorsque ni florian philippe dénervaud il
ya quand même des choses et joseph et
moi on s'est regardé ses meilleurs
épidémiologistes le monde d'accord sur
ce que je suis dit il ya beaucoup de
gens qui sont au bout du rouleau aussi
là dessus
yaalon des restaurateurs des gens qui
sont dans le spectacle des gens qui sont
un cas qui peuvent plus travailler donc
mine de rien c'est vrai qu'aujourd'hui
psychologiquement et financièrement il
ya des gens qui sont à bout regarder
joseph et joseph abaissant son sang qui
sont dans le même cas clean mais joseph
il était ce réellement se retrouver sdf
il n'a pas envie de laisser ses enfants
parce que voilà dans la panade excédents
sont plus qu'à se nourrir c'est vrai
qu'aujourd'hui joseph il est dans une
situation très compliquée c'est pas le
seul donc aujourd'hui ce que dit florian
philippot là dessus je suis désolé s'est
pas complètement s'est pas complètement
con s'est même dit les aubrais donc à
d'espagne et du ren-lac région là parce
que ya aujourd'hui il y a
on a parlé bien entendu de cette
solution voilà hybride entre confinement
par confinement donc couvre-feu et qui
resterait un peu comme ça mais
aujourd'hui même si yann moix de sony
c'est à leurs 500 morts par jour alors
c'est énorme et entendu mais il ya
ajouté à ses 500 morts des gens qui sont
en train de mourir économiquement ils
sont en train de mourir socialement qui
sont en train de mourir
psychologiquement et c'est des familles
entières comme le disait florian
philippot qui sont dans des situations
inextricables et qu'aujourd'hui
qu'est ce qu'elles vont faire c'est à
dire oui il faut des solutions parce que
là si elles n'ont pas si elles voient
pas le bout du tunnel avec des solutions
qui vont arriver si on attend après le
vaccin si on attend après telle ou telle
chose
aujourd'hui il va y avoir des drames et
vous le savez et y en a de plus en plus
et il ya des gens qui appellent à la
désobéissance civile
voilà vous en faites partie joseph
florian philippot non ici si vous avez
su créé voilà bon encore une harmonie
c'est vrai qu'aujourd'hui
non mais s'il vous plaît est donc
aujourd'hui qu'est ce qu'on dit
à ces gens moi c'est ça que j'ai envie
de savoir qu'est ce qu'on dit aux gens
qui sont dans la situation de joseph la
situation de joseph aujourd'hui cette
porte parole de dizaines de milliers de
personnes
voilà donc qu'est ce qu'on leur dit
alors date parce qu'il ya eu les aides
mais on le voit bien à chaque fois vous
avez fait les aides mais ça suffit pas
ils veulent rouvrir leurs restaurants et
paul roux ils veulent sonner comme moi
vous savez des chefs d'entreprise je
rencontre beaucoup j'en rends compte
beaucoup sur le terrain les gens qui ont
envie de travailler des gens dans la
culture des intermittents du spectacle
ou leur dit vous avez une année blanche
pour vous prend en charge
on vous donne de l'argent et je crois
qu'il ya une très grande solidarité dans
ce pays une très grande solidarité
économique qui n'a aucun ne gagne aucun
égal dans aucun autre pays européen et
mondial
ça c'est la première chose c'est pas
satisfaisant je suis la première à pas
être satisfaites
j chez la première à vouloir reprendre
une vie normale à pouvoir embrasser mes
parents à pouvoir sortir avec mes
enfants se levant ce qu'il puisse
reprendre le sandre assis au banc femmes
etc
oui je suis la première il ya toutes les
salles de sport aussi les salles de
sport qui son père mais aller au théâtre
aller au cinéma voilà c'est tout alors
qu'ils vont pouvoir tenir
alors notre travail peut plus faire de
sport notre responsabilité elle est
double c'est quoi le fondement
scientifique je veux fermeture boudé la
première chose sur naples à la première
chose c'est effectivement de faire en
sorte que cette détresse économique on y
répondent
ça c'est le quoi qu'il en coûte et je
crois que on a été au rendez vous en
termes de rapidité en termes de montant
et à chaque fois on l'a encore vu
récemment on est juste les dispositifs
pour faire en sorte on est juste
l'argent qu'on donne pour faire en sorte
que les personnes sortent la tête de
l'eau
ça c'est très clair la deuxième chose
c'est d'en finir le plus vite avec cette
épidémie en finir le plus vite avec
cette épidémie ça supposerait de savoir
comment il se termine moi je ne suis pas
médecin je n'ai pas la prétention de
lire dans le marc de café
ce que je sais c'est que tous les matins
je me lève pour trouver des doses de
vaccin pour les faire fabriquer pour
soutenir les industriels
vous savez si on fabrique coût de 100
millions de vaccins en france
là cette année et probablement encore
plus c'est pas l'opération du
saint-esprit
c'est parce que le gouvernement s'est
mobilisé au mois de juin mais s'est
mobilisée au mois de juin pour trouver
des
i mode de production pour financer des
lignes de production pour faire en sorte
qu'on ait des doses de vaccin